i mean i always had a resource as i
mentioned but not necessarily
billing um consultant so with the
resources it was kind of quite easy to
manage because i'd just you know give
them the jobs i'll go do my bd happy
days
when it becomes more billing you look
after billing consultants you're not an
individual biller anymore and i think
that's the hardest thing to get over
before ourselves how i was billing how
much i made the company how many clients
i brought in and now you have shift it's
like no race it's not about you it's
about the company
you have to leave lead from the front
and i think you have to like
understand the situation and explain why
it's happened if people are getting down
themselves i'll say well last year
you did xyz i bring them back to times
when things did go well
just being positive making people
realize that it's just a you know
former temporary class is permanent i do
really believe that
you will have times and i'll say look
i'll i'll draw back on examples when
it's happened to me
in my past just to show that there is
there is light at the end of the tunnel